aujourd'hui c'est le printemps les jours
vont être plus long que les nus c'est
une histoire de mécanique céleste vous
le savez la kz2 rotation de la terre est
incliné à 23,5 degrés est la terre
tourne autour du soleil
bon je sais mais on fait avec les moyens
du bord l'hiver l'hémisphère nord et
moins éclairé les nuits sont plus
longues que les jours aujourd'hui 20
mars
la terre se trouve dans une position
telle que les deux hémisphères sont
éclairés de la même manière le jour et
la nuit font la même durée et dès demain
les jours souvent plus longs que les
nuits et je ne vous dis pas ça parce que
nous sommes en plein confinement ça fait
quand même du bien de prendre un peu de
hauteur
une vraie capsules de déconfinement
aller à demain et n'oubliez pas nous
sommes confinés
né en restant lien si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un
pouce bleus gens réalisent une nouvelle
chaque jour alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces capsules 2d confiné abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain